PROFESSOR: And what we saw was
the performance was quite
different in the two regimes.
In power-limited regime,
typically our SNR is much
smaller than one, whereas in the
bandwidth-limited regime,
the SNR is large.
And because of this behavior
of SNR, what we saw is that
the Shannon spectral
efficiency in the
bandwidth-limited regime,
it doubles for every --
if we double our SNR.
For every 3 dB increase in SNR,
the spectral efficiency
increases by a factor of 2.
In the bandwidth limited regime,
if we have a 3 dB
increase in SNR, the spectral
efficiency increases by one
bit per two dimension.
On the other hand, if we double
our bandwidth, then the
capacity in bits per second
is not affected in the
power-limited regime.
But if we double our bandwidth,
then in the
bandwidth-limited regime,
the capacity increases
approximately by
a factor of 2.
And that's really what
motivated the name
bandwidth-limited and
power-limited regime.
If we want a more operational
definition, then we say that
the flow is less than two bits
per two dimensions, we will
have this bandwidth-limited
regime.
And in this case, rho is greater
than two bits per two
dimensions.
The number two bits per two
dimensions was chosen because
it is like the largest spectral
efficiency we can get
through binary transmission.
If it's an uncoded two-PAM over
a channel, then we get
two bits per two dimensions.
If we are coding, the only
thing we can do is reduce
spectral efficiency.
So typically, if we are going
to operate in power-limited
regime, the operational meaning
is we can get away
with binary transmission.
In the bandwidth-limited regime,
we have to resort to
non-binary transmission.
So in other words, binary
modulation is done in
power-limited regime, whereas we
need multi-level modulation
in the bandwidth-limited
regime.
The baseline system
here is 2-PAM.
The uncoded performance
was of 2-PAM.
In the bandwidth limited
regime, it is M-PAM.
And the way we measure
performance in the
power-limited regime is the
probability of bit error as a
function of EbN0.
OK?
In the bandwidth-limited
regime, the performance
measure is done by probability
of error per two dimensions as
a function of SNR norm.
And in this case, we saw that
the gap to capacity --
or rather, to put it in other
words, the ultimate limit on
EbN0 is minus 1.59 dB.
And here, the ultimate limit
on SNR norm is 0 dB.
OK?
Any questions on this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why do we use Eb
over N_0 SNR norm for
[INAUDIBLE]
bandwidth limited?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
AUDIENCE: Why do we use Eb over
N_0 for both regimes?
PROFESSOR: Or why don't use
SNR norm for both regimes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Now if we think about
the bandwidth limited
regime, what we really
care about is
spectral efficiency, right?
What SNR norm does, if you
remember the definition, is
that it compass the amount of
SNR we require for a practical
system to that of the best
possible system.
So in other words, if you
do care about spectral
efficiency, SNR norm is the
right measure to look for.
OK, now what happens in the
power-limited regime?
It turns out, probably more for
historic reasons, people
started with EbN0 in the
power-limited regime.
And if you look at the
definition of EbN0, it is SNR
over rho, right?
So in the power limited regime,
our rho is small, the
SNR is going to be small, but
if you look at -- because we
are in the power limited regime
so we have lots of
bandwidth, so our SNR is going
to be small and the spectral
efficiency is going
to be small.
But if you look at the ratio
between the two, it's going to
be greater than minus 1.59 dB.
OK.
so it turns out that the kind of
limit we do take, our EbN0
remains constant as minus 1.59
dB, and that's probably one of
the reasons that motivated
to use EbN0 in the
power limited regime.
On the other hand, one could
also argue is that what really
happens in the power limited
regime is that our bandwidth
becomes really large.
So if this [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
stick with 2-PAM system, then
we do get a spectral
efficiency of two bits per two
dimensions, but that's just
because we are using a
particular modulation scheme.
If our bandwidth is really
large, we are not really going
to care about what spectral
efficiency we use.
What really matters is this
energy per bit, and that's why
this is a reasonable
assumption.
Does that answer
your question?
Right, it's not completely clear
as to why this EbN0 is
the best here, and SNR norm is
here if you don't take the
limit rho going to zero here,
but again, you can think of it
more as a convention.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So if you look in the
power-limited regime, you
are saying rho is less than two
bits per two dimensions.
If you use an uncoded 2-PAM,
what's your spectral
efficiency?
It's two bits per two
dimension, right?
Now the idea is, suppose we want
to design a system with
spectral efficiency greater
than two bits per two
dimensions?
We cannot really use
a 2-PAM system.
Because if you put coding on top
of it, all we are going to
do is simply reduce the spectral
efficiency below two
bits per two dimension.
So we have to start with a
non-binary modulation, right?
So that's how we distinguish
between power-limited and
bandwidth-limited
AUDIENCE: That's just because
you're using the 2-PAM as your
baseline [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK?
All right.
So let us do an example to
finish off this analysis.
Now suppose --
say you are at a summer project,
and you're assigned
to design some system.
Your boss gives you some
specifications, like
continuous time specifications.
In particular, you have
a baseband system.
The baseband system has a
bandwidth of one Megahertz.
You have a power, P, which is
one unit, so that's another
resource you have.
And if you measure your channel,
it can be reasonably
approximated as an AWGN channel,
so there is no ISI or
any filtering going on, just
Additive White Gaussian Noise.
And your noise a single sided
spectral density of ten to the
minus six units per Hertz
of the bandwidth.
And what is your goal?
So you have the following
goal.
Design a 2-PAM system,
with a specified
probability of bit error.
And what you want to do is
compare this to the ultimate
Shannon limit.
So that is your objective.
So since we have to compare it
with Shannon limit, and we
have already a formula for the
Shannon limit, let's just
start with that.
So for this problem, we have
the Shannon limit.
You have rho is less than log
base 2 of 1 plus SNR.
For SNR, I can talk in terms
of this continuous time
parameters, it's P over N_0 W.
My P is one unit, and nought
is ten to the minus six, and
my bandwidth, W, is one
Megahertz here, which
is ten to the six.
So my P over N_0 W
is basically one.
So I have 1 plus
1, which is 2.
This is log base
2 of 2, or it's
one bit per two dimension.
So my capacity in bits per
second is rho W, and rho is
one bit per two dimension, the
bandwidth is one Megahertz.
So I get ten to the six
bits per second.
So this is my Shannon
capacity for this
particular AWGN system.
OK.
The next thing we want to do
is compare this with a
practical system, and
see how close we get
to the Shannon limit.
And since you only have to work
with 2-PAM, the generic
architecture is something
we saw last time.
You have input bits coming in,
let's call them X sub k, where
k is the kth bit.
And they belong to a certain
constellation,
let's call the --
the constellation points are
just -- it's a 2-PAM system,
so we have minus alpha
and alpha.
And this goes through a PAM
modulator, and one parameter
to specify for the
PAM modulator
is the symbol interval.
Right, the time between sending
consecutive signals
over the channel.
What you get out is X
of t, this is the
channel model, N of t.
There's already noise over
the channel, and what you
get out is Y of t.
So this is the generic
architecture.
And now, your goal for the
design problem is to select
alpha and t in the right way,
so that they satisfy this
continuous time constraints, and
at the same time, you have
your probability of error of
ten to the minus five.
So what would be an obvious
choice for T?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the first idea is you are
given a certain amount of
bandwidth, and you clearly want
send your signals as fast
as possible in order to get
excellent data rate.
Now because you have a certain
amount of bandwidth, what
Nyquist's criteria tells
you is that you want
to have zero ISI.
And if you want to have zero
ISI, what you do know is that
the symbol interval should
be greater than or
equal to 1 over 2W.
You cannot signal at a rate
faster than one over T, and so
if we look at this, it's 1
over 2 times 10 to the 6.
Now it I do use this particular
value of T, then
what's my alpha going to be?
Well, alpha is simply the
energy per symbol.
So I know alpha squared is the
power that I have times the
symbol interval, T. It's
just a definition.
This comes from orthonormality
of the PAM
system that we have.
Now P is one, because that's
what I specified as a system
specification, so this is just
T, which is one over times ten
to the six.
So I can select this value of
alpha and this value of T.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, alpha squared
is energy per symbol.
So what will that be?
What's the energy per symbol,
if you're sending every T
seconds, and if you
have a power of P?
Es, that I mentioned last
time, or energy per two
dimensions.
So in PAM, it will be
energy per symbols.
In that case, it will be 2P.
OK.
But now if I select these values
of alpha and T, will my
system work?
Is this a reasonable
design, or is there
something wrong here?
I'm clearly satisfying my --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The probability
of error, right, exactly.
So in fact, I do know how
to calculate it, right?
What's the probability
of bit error?
Well, we saw that last time it
was Q of root 2 Eb over N_0.
Eb is same as alpha squared,
because we
have one bit per symbol.
So alpha squared is this
quantity here, 1 over 2 times
10 to the 6.
So this is Q of square
root of --
so 2 alpha squared is 10 to
the 6, 1 over 10 to the 6.
N_0, I know, is ten to the
minus six, so this is
actually Q of 1.
And if I do calculate that, it's
like 17 percent, which is
nowhere close to ten
to the minus five.
So any suggestions on how
I can improve my system?
AUDIENCE: Increase
T [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Increase T, right?
What's happening
right now is --
the reason we selected this
value of T in the first place
is because we wanted to send
our signals as fast as
possible avoid ISI, but that's
just one of criteria in my
system, right?
I have to also satisfy this
probability of error criteria,
so I want to make sure my
probability of error is going
to be small.
If I look at the expression for
probability of error, it
doesn't really look at T. All
it looks at is this ratio of
Eb/N0, right?
So if I want to reduce my
probability of error, I have
to increase my energy per bit.
Now my energy per bit is P times
T, so the only hope of
increasing my energy per bit
will be to increase T, which
means I have to signal
at a slower rate.
OK?
So we have probability of --
let's write the calculation
down.
It's ten to the minus five.
Last time, we saw that the best
way to solve this is to
look at the waterfall curve,
and EbN_0 in this case is
approximately 9.6 dB.
I will say that that's
approximately ten on the
linear scale.
So this implies that energy
per bit is ten
to the minus five.
So energy per bit is P times T,
in this case, it's ten to
the minus five. p is one, so
this implies that t is ten to
the minus five.
So I can send one bit every ten
to the minus five seconds.
So my rate that I achieve --
just write it here --
which is ten to the five
bits per second.
OK?
If you compare this to the
Shannon limit, the Shannon
limit is right here,
you have ten to the
six bits per second.
So you lose by a factor of ten
in your data rate if you're
going to use an uncoded
2-PAM system.
So what this example tells you
is that if you're going to do
more sophisticated cording, you
can gain up to a factor of
ten in your data rate.
So if the 10 dB did not really
impress you last time,
hopefully this example
throws more light on
the value of coding.
Are there any questions
on this example?
AUDIENCE: Since the --
since we are signaling at a
faster rate now, instead of
using sink process, we can
use something better.
PROFESSOR: That's a very
good point, yes.
Well, if you look at the nominal
bandwidth here, it's 1
over 2T, right?
T is 10 to the minus 5 seconds,
so this says 1 over 2
times 10 to the minus 5.
So it's going to be 5 times
10 to the 4, or 50 KHz.
OK?
The available bandwidth you
have, the system bandwidth, if
you will, is 1 Megahertz.
But if you're going to do
Nyquist's ideal sinks pulses,
then you only need 50
KHz of bandwidth in
your system, right?
So one advantage of this system,
if you will, is that
you're not required to do the
complicated sink pulses.
Do not need to send
those pulses.
You could simply send, for
example, square pulses and,
because your bandwidth is such
low, you have a very low
complexity system.
Of course, the price you pay is
you reduce the data rate by
a factor of ten.
OK, it's a good point.
In fact, there are many points
that will come up in this
example if you think about it
later on, so feel free to ask
me questions if you think about
some issues later on.
Ok.
So I think we have motivated
the need for coding enough
now, so let's look at
our encoder design.
So a typical encoder design
takes bits in --
we saw this last time
in the context of
spectral efficiency --
and produces symbols out.
So I can represent my bits by,
say a vector b, and I can
represent my symbols
by a vector x.
So every sequence of b
bits gets mapped to a
sequence of N symbols.
Now this output sequence of
symbols is not any arbitrary
sequence, but it lies in a set
of all possible sequences,
which I denote by C. And this
set is essentially a set of
permissible output symbol
sequences, which I will write
by C sub j, which is a vector
in Rn, because there are N
symbols being produced.
And we can have set up to j, j
goes from 1 to M. So we can
have up to M symbols.
And note that here, M has to
be equal to 2 to the b, in
order to be able to
map every sequence
of b bits to M symbols.
So this C is known as a
codebook, and each C sub j is
called a codeword.
OK?
The standard definition
of an encoder.
Now in today's lecture and half
of next week's lecture,
we will be seeing at a very
specific case when N
equals 1 and 2.
In that case, instead of using
the letter C, we will be using
a different letter, A. So C,
in that case, we'll call it
actually a constellation.
So in particular if C is one,
it's a PAM constellation.
If N is 2, it's a QAM
constellation.
And we'll be denoting it by
a letter A instead of C.
So A is again, a sequence of
symbols a_j, which belongs to
Rn, where one is less than j
is less than M. OK, in this
case a is a constellation.
a_j's are known as symbols, or
sometimes they're also known
as signal points in
the constellation.
There are a number of
definitions that
follow from this --
number of properties of
the constellation,
rather, that follow.
So in particular N is known
as the dimension of your
constellation.
The number N is this, and
here, it's the number of
symbol sequences you output
for a sequence of b
bits that are in.
M is the size of your
constellation.
The energy per constellation is
given by 1 over M times the
summation the norm of a_j
squared, where j goes from one
to M. The minimum distance of
your constellation is simply
the Euclidean minimum distance
between two points in the
constellation.
So if you take the norm of a_i
minus a_j, and minimize it
over all possible
values i and j.
The number of nearest neighbors,
of the average
number of nearest --
K_min of A is the average number
of nearest neighbors in
A.
In addition to this, there
are some orthonormalized
parameters that you
saw last time.
The spectral efficiency, which
is in units of bits per two
dimensions is 2b over N. And if
you want to eliminate b, we
use the relation that b is
log M to the base 2 here.
And so we have 2 log M
to the base 2 over N.
The energy per two dimensions,
denoted by Es, is simply 2
over N E(A).
So E(A) is the average energy
of your constellation.
If you divide it by the number
of dimensions you have, you
get energy per dimension, and
you multiply it by 2.
And finally, the energy per bit
is Es over rho, or it can
also be expressed as E(A), which
is the energy per symbol
over the number of bits per
symbol, which is log
M to the base 2.
It might seem like a lot of
definitions, but you will see
very soon that they have a very
tight interplay among one
another, so it's not nearly as
overwhelming as it might seem
at the first point.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why is
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Because you have two
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] b bits
coming in, right, which
you map to each --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
There are two [INAUDIBLE]
possible sequences, but all of
them need not be used, right?
PROFESSOR: Well, we assume that
there is no coding going
on before the encoder.
So you have the source code, for
which there's a sequence
of IID bits, and then
they mapped to
a sequence of symbols.
So we'll see all of our possible
input bits coming in
here, because it's produced
by a source code,
like a Huffman code.
Right?
And the idea here is, perhaps
what you're asking is --
this did not span the
entire space of Rn.
We want to select these
sequences carefully here.
Maybe we'll come back to that
later on in the course.
OK, so let's do an example.
So the example is, say we have
A, which is a 2-PAM system,
and you want to look at this
constellation, B, which is
denoted by A raised to K. The
definition of A raised to k is
it's a sequence of K symbols
where each x_i belongs to A.
So this is also known as the
K-fold Cartesian product of A.
AUDIENCE: Another question.
So it has been pre-decided that
b bits will be encoded
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So this is a specific structure
we are imposing on
the encoder.
So this is the constellation,
and you'll want to study the
properties for this
constellation.
For this constellation,
what's N going to be?
What's the dimension
going to be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: For B, not A. It's
going to be K. Well, the
number of points in this
constellation, how
many points are there?
There are K coordinates.
Each coordinate can be
plus or minus alpha.
So we have 2 to the K possible
points in this constellation.
OK?
What's E of A going to be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: K alpha
squared. right?
Basically, we have
K coordinates.
The energy for each coordinate
will simply add up.
The energy across each
coordinate is always going to
be alpha squared.
So each point in this
constellation has an energy of
K alpha squared.
So regardless of how many points
we have, the average
energy is always going to
be K alpha squared.
Does everybody see this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You're right.
Maybe that was the confusion.
It's a good thing.
Just getting too used to
writing E of A. OK.
What's d_min of b going to be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
2 alpha.
PROFESSOR: 2 alpha.
I think everybody had
the right idea.
So the minimum distance here is
two alpha for A. If we look
at this point B, we can fix K
minus 1 coordinates for two
points to be the same, they will
only differ in one point.
And so the minimum distance
is across that
point, which is 2 alpha.
What is K_min of
B going to be?
It's going to be K. For each
point -- let's say the point
which has all alphas, we can fix
K minus 1 coordinate and
find another point which is
different in only one of the
coordinates, say the
first coordinate.
We can do it for all K different
coordinates, so
K_min is going to be K for
each point, and hence the
average number of nearest
neighbors is also K.
OK, so now in this case, let's
first start with the
normalized parameters.
That's always good to start
with spectral efficiency.
That's 2 log M over N. Well, log
of M is going to be K, so
N is going to be K. So this is
going to be two bits per two
dimensions, and this is the same
as that of the original
constellation, A. Your energy
per two dimensions is going to
be 2 over N E(B).
E(B) is K alpha squared, N
equals K, so this is 2 alpha
squared, and that is the same as
the original constellation,
A.
Finally.
energy per bit is Es over
rho, so it's 2 alpha
squared over 2.
So that's alpha squared, and
that's same as the 2-PAM
constellation.
So why did I go through all
of these calculations?
What we see is that the
normalized parameters, rho,
Es, and Eb, are the same for the
Cartesian product as for
the original constellation.
And at some level, that should
not be too surprising, right?
Because what I'll be doing in
this Cartesian product, we are
not really doing any
coding, right?
In this original constellation,
we had one bit
coming in, and we are mapping
it to one symbol.
All we are doing in the
Cartesian product is we are
taking K bits in and mapping
them to K symbols.
So we still have one
bit per symbol.
The noise is IID, so it's
optimal to two decisions for
each of the coordinates
independently, and decide
whether that coordinate
corresponds to plus alpha or
minus alpha.
So in other words, there's
nothing gained by doing this
Cartesian product.
And we will see, the probability
of error
expression depends on these
normalized parameters, if we
want to look at Pb of E, and so
we do not gain anything in
terms of the probability of
error, versus EbN_0, trade-off
through Cartesian product.
So I'm making the note here
because that's the
only space I have.
So the note is if I look at
probability of bit error
versus EbN_0, the curve we saw
last time, it is the same for
B and A. You should be able to
convince yourself about this,
and so there is really no
coding going on here.
Are there any questions
on this?
Let's look at this problem
a bit more carefully now.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: What does he use?
PROFESSOR: Energy per
two dimensions.
Es will always be energy
per two dimensions.
Throughout the course, we'll
be using these notations.
Eb is the energy per bit,
Es is the energy per two
dimensions.
And if you want to say energy
per symbol, we'll be using
this notation E sub
the constellation.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
It's not energy per bit.
PROFESSOR: No, this
is energy --
B is my constellation.
So that's why it's energy of
that constellation, average
energy per symbol in
that constellation.
OK, so let us consider the
special case when K equals 3.
So in that case, B is A^q.
So if I look at all possible
points in B, they are going to
lie on the vertices of a
three-dimensional cube.
That's a Cartesian product
in three dimensions.
And all my constellations points
are basically on the
vertices of this cube.
The distance here is going
to be 2 alpha.
That's the length of each edge
in my cube, and that's what B
is going to be.
Clearly, the minimum distances
is 2 alpha, as we saw before.
Now let me define a different
constellation, B prime, and
only going to take four vertices
from these possible
eight vertices.
I'm going to take this vertex
here, I'm going to take this
vertex here, this one,
and this one.
I'm only taking four vertices.
If I want to tell you explicitly
what the points
are, I need to draw an axis, so
I'm simply drawing the x,
y, and z axis here.
This is x-axis, this is
y-axis, and z-axis.
And B prime is a subset
of the points in this
three-dimensional Cartesian
product.
They will be alpha, alpha,
alpha; minus alpha, minus
alpha, alpha; alpha, minus
alpha, minus alpha; and let's
see, minus alpha, alpha,
minus alpha.
So two of the coordinates will
be minus alpha here, in these
three points, and we have one
coordinate all alphas.
So this is my B prime.
What is the minimum distance
going to be for B prime?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 2 over
2 alpha, right?
It's basically the length
of this edge here.
This is 2 alpha, this
is 2 alpha.
So it's 2 over 2 alpha.
So in other words, by simply
selecting a subset of points,
I have been able to increase
my minimum distance.
Because my minimum distance
is larger, I hope that the
probability of error will be
smaller as opposed to the
original constellation.
But this comes at the
price, right?
And what's the price?
The spectral efficiency
is smaller, right?
What if I look at my spectral
efficiency?
Well, I'm only sending
out two points, two
bits per each point.
So two bits, each point takes
three dimensions, so my
spectral efficiency is 2 times
2 over 3 bits per two
dimensions, or it's 4 over 3
bits per two dimensions.
And this is in contrast to the
two bits per two dimensions we
had for B.
So in other words, there is
a trade-off between your
spectral efficiency and
the minimum distance.
We'll start with a K-dimensional
Cartesian
product of A, which
has all points.
We took a subset of points, and
if we chose them smartly,
we were able to increase the
minimum distance, but the
price we had to pay was
to reduce the spectral
efficiency.
AUDIENCE: Where did this
two / three come from?
PROFESSOR: This two here?
AUDIENCE: 2/3, yes.
PROFESSOR: 2/3, I am sending
two bits per symbol, right?
Each symbol has three
dimensions.
So it's 2/3 bit per dimension,
or 4/3 bit per two dimension.
OK, so the point was it seems
like there is a trade-off
between minimum distance and
spectral efficiency.
And indeed, this might seem like
a reasonable trade-off,
and a lot of coding here that we
will be seeing in the early
part of the course is indeed
motivated by this trade-off.
You want to reduce your spectral
efficiency in order
to increase your probability
of error.
And this has in fact been
quite a dominant design
principle for a large number of
codes that have come up in
coding theory.
However, if you look at what
Shannon says, Shannon says
something quite different.
In Shannon's theorem, all
they say is, you have --
if your spectral efficiency is
below a certain amount, then
your probability of bit error
can be made arbitrarily small.
OK, so what Shannon is saying,
it's something much stronger
than this trade-off.
It's saying if you reduce your
spectral efficiency below a
certain quantity which is
finite, then the probability
of error can be made
arbitrarily small.
There is no statement of minimum
distance in this
theorem here.
And indeed, if you look at the
most modern codes which are
capacity approaching, they are
not designed to maximize the
minimum distance.
They are designed to work well
with some practical decoding
algorithms, like the belief
propagation of
algorithms and so on.
So they are designed on a
somewhat different principle
than minimum distance.
But nevertheless, this is quite
a powerful tool that we
will be using in the early
part of this course.
We start with a K-dimensional
Cartesian product, select a
subset of points, and we want
to increase the minimum
distance at the cost of
spectral efficiency.
OK.
Now are there any questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
Suppose I have a 2-PAM
constellation, then I can
easily write the probability of
bit error as a function of
Q function.
If it is a more complicated
expression, I have to
integrate over the decision
regions, which we'll be seeing
later on in this lecture.
And it's not usually possible to
get an exact probability of
error expression.
We usually use an in-union
bound, to bound it by a pair
of [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
error probability.
We'll be doing all
that just now.
OK.
So now let us --
I have talked now enough now
about encoder, and we'll be
visiting it very soon, but let
us switch gears and talk about
the decoder now.
OK, what does a decoder do?
So the goal of a decoder
is the following.
You get your received vector Y,
which is X plus N, and from
Y, you want to estimate X-hat
as a point in your signal
constellation.
So you receive a noisy version
of X, and you want to estimate
X-hat at the decoder.
So this is the architecture
of your decoder.
And the goal here is you
want to minimize the
probability of error.
And what's the probability
of error?
It's basically probability that
X is not equal to X-hat.
So that is your general criteria
at the decoder.
Now what we'll doing next is
basically going through this
exercise to show that this
minimum probability of error
criteria is equivalent to a
bunch of other criteria.
So the first criteria is the
MAP criteria: Maximum
A-Posteriori Rule.
So our probability of error
is basically --
I can track it as an integral of
probability of error given
Y times the density function of
Y. So if I want to minimize
my probability of error, I want
to minimize each term in
this integral.
So this implies I want to
minimize probability of error
given Y for each possible
value of Y. OK?
Now what's that going to be?
Well, in order to look
at what this term is,
suppose I make a decision.
I receive Y, and I decide
a symbol a_j is sent.
Then what's the probability
of error going to be?
My probability of error given
Y is going to be 1 minus the
probability that
I was correct.
Probability that I was correct
is probability X equals a_j,
given Y. This follows
from the definition.
So if I want to minimize my
probability of error given Y,
I want to actually choose an
a_j that maximizes the
probability of a_j given Y. So
this implies, choose a_j.
And this is known
as the MAP rule.
So the idea behind the MAP rule
is to choose the symbol
in the constellation that
maximizes the posterior
probability, given the
received symbol.
Now, this MAP rule is equivalent
to the maximum
likelihood rule, under the
assumption that all the signal
points a_j are equally likely.
The proof is not hard,
you just use
Bayes Theorem for that.
So suppose all a_j's
are equally likely.
Then probability of a_j given
Y, which by Bayes Theorem is
the density of Y given a_j,
times the probability of a_j.
But since all a_j's are equally
likely, I will just
write it as 1 over M, over the
density of Y. Now because Y is
fixed, the density of Y is
fixed, so this quantity is
just proportional to --
the proportionality symbol --
to the density of Y given a_j.
I won't be writing all
the vectors, I
might be missing some.
But please bear with me.
So this implies we want to
choose a_j that maximizes the
density of Y given a_j, and this
is known as the maximum
likelihood rule.
And there is one final rule.
Basically if the noise is
additive Gaussian, then the
density of Y given a_j is
simply proportional to E
raised to minus the norm
of Y minus a_j squared.
So if we want to maximize this
quantity, we want to minimize
Y minus a_j squared.
So we want to choose a_j that
minimizes the Euclidean
distance between Y minus a_j.
And this is known as the minimum
distance decision
rule, MDD rule.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: We are ignoring
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: We are ignoring
P value.
Because for a given Y, Py is
going to be fixed for all
possible choices of a_j.
The goal is I'm given Y, and I
want to decide which signal
point was set, because that's
the probability of error given
Y. This is my criteria now.
So Y is fixed, so the density
of Y is fixed.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's basically
given by --
in order to find this density,
we'll just condition it on
a_j, and sum up over all
possible values of a_j.
Just take the marginal
of Y, right?
I mean, to write this
explicitly.
I'm writing it here.
It's going to be sigma P of
Y given a_j that's the
probability of a_j.
And this you can find
by the Gaussian.
AUDIENCE: But then you
have [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: But this is
a summation over
all possible a_j's.
I should write, sorry
-- a_k's.
This is just a summation
over all k's, right?
So basically, Py is going to
be a mixture of several
Gaussians, OK?
And it's fixed.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK.
So we want to choose the Minimum
Distance Decision
rule, and I should have the
variance of noise here.
OK, so what we have so far is
we started with the Minimum
Probability of Error rule,
and that's the
criteria of your decoder.
Be sure this is equivalent to
MAP rule, and that basically
comes just from the
definition.
This integral here, we want to
minimize each term in the
integral, and that basically
implies that the Maximum
A-Posteriori rule is the best.
This implied Maximum Likelihood
rule, and Maximum
Likelihood rule comes from the
fact that all the signal
points are equally likely.
And this implies, then, the
Minimum Distance Decision
rule, and that comes from the
fact that your noise is
Additive Gaussian.
So you have an exponential
in the --
you have the Euclidean distance
as an exponent, and
you want to minimize the
Euclidean distance.
So this is the story
we have so far.
And it turns out that the
Minimum Distance Decision rule
is actually quite nice, because
it gives you a lot of
geometrical insights.
So say I have three points.
We not even draw the
coordinates.
My constellation, A, has three
points, and let me write them
as a1, a2, a3.
This is my constellation,
for example.
And say I receive a symbol Y.
Then the job of the decoder is
to figure out whether
I sent a1, a2 or a3.
How will the decoder do that?
Well, it will measure the
distance from all the three
constellation points and
select the one with the
smallest Euclidean distance.
More generally, what we want
to do is we want to look at
the space of all received Y
symbols, and partition it into
decision regions.
So that if the point falls in a
certain decision region, we
say that the constellation point
corresponding to that
decision region was sent.
And how do I find the
decision region?
Well, I start drawing
hyperplanes between every two
pair of constellation points.
Say I want to find the decision
region of point a1.
I draw a hyperplane between
a1 and a3, which is
given by this line.
I draw a hyperplane between
a1 and a2 which is
given by this point.
And so the region -- the set of
points which are closer to
a1 than a2 and a3 is basically
bounded by this region here.
So this is my R1.
Similarly, if I want to find a
decision region for a2 and a3,
I will draw this line here.
This will be R2 and
this will be R3.
So these are my decision
regions.
So if I want to write
that formally, Rj
is my decision region.
And it is the set of points Y
belong to Rn, such that the
norm of Y minus a_j squared is
going to be less than or equal
to -- it doesn't matter if you
have less than or equal to,
because the point
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] bound
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] probability
zero --
is radius squared.
That's just the definition
of Rj.
Now the way to construct Rj was
to look at all the half
planes which are closer to
this point than any other
point, and take the
intersection of
all the half planes.
So in other words, I can
also write Rj to be the
intersection of these
half planes --
the intersections over all
points, j prime not equal to j
-- of Rj, j prime.
So Rj, j prime is your
half plane where --
so norm of Y minus a_j prime
squared is greater than or
equal to norm of Y minus
a_j squared.
Note that this is a_j prime,
and this is a_j here.
OK.
So it turns out that this
decision region has a somewhat
nice structure, because they're
intersection of a
bunch of half planes, their
shape is the convex polytope.
And they're also known by the
name Voronoi regions.
OK, so these regions are known
as Voronoi regions here.
Now the set of points whose
hyperplanes are active in a
certain decision region has a
special name, too, and it's
called the relevant subset.
So in this case, the relevant
subset of a1 is a2 and a3,
because both of them have
hyperplanes that are active in
the decision region of a1.
So let me write that down.
So the relevant subset is the
set of points, a_j prime,
whose hyperplanes are active
in this decision region Rj.
There's a theorem which says
that the nearest neighbors are
always included in the
relevant subset.
It's asserted in your notes.
OK?
So now that we have this Minimum
Distance Decision
rule, let us see if we can
get a hang with the
probability of error.
Let me see the probability of
error, given that I sent a
symbol, a_j.
I want the value that
probability of error.
That's simply the probability
that Y does not belong to Rj,
given that I sent
the symbol a_j.
That's when an error happens.
That's same as probability
that the noise vector --
because Y is a_j plus N now --
does not belong to the Rj minus
a_j, and the noise is
independent of a_j so I remove
the conditioning.
And that is 1 minus the
probability that the noise
does belong to Rj minus a_j.
If I want to find this
integral, find this
expression, I will integrate
over the region Rj minus a_j,
of the density of
the noise, dN.
No note that the noise has
a spherical symmetry, but
unfortunately despite that,
the integral is not a
straightforward integral,
because this region here has
sharp edges.
The decision region is a convex
polytope, so it's
typically something like this,
and if this was your point,
a_j, your noise does have a
spherical symmetry about these
spheres, but when it intersects
the decision
boundary, things get ugly.
And so this decision
-- this is not a
nice integral in general.
And so unfortunately, there is
not much progress we can make
beyond this point for the exact
probability of error
expression, but we can say
some nice geometrical
properties about the probability
of error.
The first property is that
probability of error is
invariant to translations.
And this should be
quite obvious.
You have, say, a constellation
with two points here, and say
I subtract off the mean.
So I get a different
constellation whose
points are like this.
This is my constellation,
A, and this is my
constellation, A prime.
The probability of error will
be same for the two
constellations because the
decision regions will have the
same distance from
both the points.
This should be quite obvious.
And basically, what this really
says is if I have any
constellation, I can always
subtract off the mean, and get
another constellation with the
same probability of error, but
with smaller average energy.
And so this implies that any
optimal constellation will
have zero mean.
The second point is, the
probability of error is
invariant to orthonormal
rotations.
So if I had, say, one point, one
constellation, with these
four points, and I rotate it by
45 degrees, what I get is
another constellation with
these four points.
And both these constellations
are simply rotations of one
another, and they have the same
probability of error.
And the easiest way to see that
is the decision regions
here are simply the
four quadrants.
And if I want to integrate my
probability of error, I will
be integrating it over
this region.
Here, my decision regions will
be these 45 degree lines.
And if I want to integrate the
probability of error for this
point here, it will be given by
noise, which is symmetric
about these circles.
Basically, since the noise is
invariant to orthonormal
rotations, it should be quite
obvious that the probability
of error is invariant
to rotations.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Any rotation,
right.
AUDIENCE: So what do you mean
by [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Basically, you're
preserving the distance.
So you're just rotating the
point, not scaling it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Unitarily.
OK?
I mean you will be proving these
properties in the next
homework, which is
just handed out.
AUDIENCE: So those
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
hold, because Minimum Distance
rule is orthonormal, right?
And that's because you
assume Gaussian --
PROFESSOR: Because you assume
Gaussian noise.
AUDIENCE: So that's the only
assumption we make?
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: -- for those
[INAUDIBLE], right?
PROFESSOR: I think so.
AUDIENCE: Why [INAUDIBLE]
constellation
must have zero mean?
PROFESSOR: Because if I have any
constellation, there's a
certain probability
of error, right?
Can always subtract out the mean
from the constellation, I
get a new constellation with a
smaller average energy with
the same probability of error.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so in terms
of [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
If you're looking at a trade-off
of probability of
error versus energy, usually
what we look at.
So maybe that's a good point.
I should just mention it.
For probability of
error versus --
we're looking at this
trade-off here.
Ok.
The next idea is to basically
bound the probability of error
by a union bound, because we
cannot compute an exact
expression for the probability
of error, so we might as well
compute a bound which
is tractable.
So we'll look at what is known
as the pairwise error
probability.
So the idea behind pairwise
error probability is suppose I
send a point, a_j, what is the
probability that instead of
a_j at the receiver, I decide
that a_j prime was sent.
This is the pairwise
error probability.
So geometrically, say a_j and
a_j prime are two points here.
Let me draw some coordinate
axis here.
And say I sent point a_j, and
there is noise on the channel,
that takes me to this point.
So this is my Y, and this
is the noise vector.
OK?
And now what I want to know is
under what conditions will I
decide a_j prime over a_j.
What is the probability of
deciding a_j prime over a_j?
So let's draw a line joining
a_j prime and a_j.
So how would I decide --
suppose I receive this point,
Y, and I wanted to decide
between a_j and a_j prime.
What would be my
decision rule?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Uh-huh.
PROFESSOR: You select --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
a_j prime.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
An equivalent way of saying it
is to project Y onto this
line, a_j prime minus a_j.
We take two projections, one
orthonormal to the line, one
along on the line, and receive
this projection.
This is a straight
line like this.
Let's call it n tilde.
I should change my chalk, it's
getting too blunt now.
This projection here is closer
to a_j prime or a_j.
So in other words, this
probability of error is same
as the probability that this n
tilde, which is the projection
of Y onto a_j prime minus a_j,
is greater than or equal to
the norm of a_j prime
minus a_j over 2.
OK, now why did I use the
notation n tilde here?
Because the projection Y onto
a_j, which is this.
n tilde is same as the
projection of the noise onto a
line joining a_j prime
minus a_j.
So n tilde, I can write it as
projection of N onto a_j prime
minus a_j over the norm.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Why, exactly?
PROFESSOR: You can just see
geometrically, right?
This is a 90 degree here.
This is the noise.
If I project the noise, it will
be this component here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right.
This should be 90, I'm sorry.
This is 90.
I'm messing things up.
OK, this is the noise here.
This noise, if I project it onto
a_j prime minus a_j, it's
going to be this component.
This is Y, if I project it,
it's the same component.
Now, if the noise is IID with
variance sigma squared in each
coordinate, we are simply
projecting the noise onto one
orthonormal vector.
So n tilde is also Gaussian,
with zero mean
variance sigma squared.
So we can use that to find this
probability of error.
So in that case, the probability
of error --
I should write this --
probability of a_j prime going
to a_j is simply probability
that this Gaussian is greater
than some distance, and that's
Q of norm of a_j prime minus
a_j over two sigma.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What is sigma?
PROFESSOR: So the noise vector
is IID, in each of the
components, and has a variance
of sigma squared.
Sigma is basically N_0 over 2,
if your noise is flat with --
so let me just write
that down, sigma
squared is N_0 over 2.
If you have an AWGN channel,
and you project it on each
orthonormal signal, that's
what you get.
AUDIENCE: What if you project
the noise vector on
[INAUDIBLE]
why is [INAUDIBLE]
you don't have --
PROFESSOR: So you have
a noise vector.
If you have a Gaussian vector,
and you project it onto an
orthonormal basis --
AUDIENCE: Yes.
But [INAUDIBLE] normal?
PROFESSOR: Right.
[INAUDIBLE]
We are only projecting out on
one vector which you need now.
AUDIENCE: So then
you're saying --
OK, yeah.
The assumption is the noise is
symmetric in all dimensions?
PROFESSOR: Right.
Let's do this algebraically, so
you're convinced that there
is no magic I'm doing here.
So we can write this as you
said, as the probability that
the norm of Y minus a_j squared
is greater than norm
of Y minus a_j prime squared,
given that Y [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
a_j, so Y is a_j plus
the noise vector.
So I sub in for Y. What I get
is probability that Y is a_j
plus N. So here I have norm of
N squared is greater than or
equal to norm of a_j plus N
minus a_j prime squared.
And since the only random
variable here is this noise,
N, I can remove the conditioning
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
down there.
Let me expand this second
norm term there.
That's basically the norm of
a_j minus a_j prime squared
plus the norm of N squared
minus two times the
projection of N --
or rather, the inner
product of N --
and a_j prime minus a_j.
So this is the probability that
the inner product of N
and a_j prime minus a_j is
greater than or equal to norm
of a_j prime minus a_j
squared over 2.
If you divide by the norm of a_j
prime minus a_j, you get
the same expression as we had.
So it's the same thing.
This was done geometrically,
this is done algebraically.
So this is the expression of the
probability of error, and
this is Q of the norm of a_j
prime minus a_j over 2 sigma.
So now that we have the pairwise
error probability, we
can use it to bound
the probability
of error given a_j.
Well by definition, the probably
of error given a_j is
simply the probability of the
union of all the possible
error events of the a_j goes to
a_j prime over all possible
j prime, not equal to j.
This by the union bound is
less than or equal to the
summations of the probability
that a_j goes to a_j prime.
That's just using union bound.
And now I can sub that
expression over from there.
This is the same as..So the
summation is over j prime not
equal to j times Q of the
norm of a_j prime
minus a_j over 2 sigma.
Now let me write the summation
in a different way.
I'm going to write the summation
over all possible
distances which belong to the
set of distance, times K_D of
a_j, times Q of D
over 2 sigma.
Where the set D is the
set of all possible
distances from a_j.
Ok?
And K_D of a_j is the
number of points at
distance D from a_j.
That's just a straightforward
change of variables.
Now if you look at this
expression, then Q of B over 2
sigma basically behaves like an
exponential, for an algebra
use of the argument.
So recall that Q of X is like
half E to the minus X squared
over 2, for X much
larger than 1.
So what you are really seeing
here is that you have a sum of
a bunch of exponentials,
each written by this
term, K_D of a_j.
Now if you think about the
argument being large, then
when you have a sum of
exponentials, the term with
the smallest exponent will
dominate, because they are all
decreasing exponentials.
So this term can be written as
approximately K_min of a_j
times Q of d_min over 2 sigma.
So what I am doing is I'm
only picking up one
term from this summation.
So far, we have a strict upper
bound here, so this summation
is a strict upper bound on the
probability of error given
a_j, But now what I am doing is
I'm only going to keep one
term in the summation, the term
which has the smallest
exponent here.
So I'm looking at the smallest
value of D in this set of
possible distances from a_j.
AUDIENCE: So you're
just looking
at the nearest neighbor.
PROFESSOR: You're looking at
essentially the nearest
neighbor, geometrically
speaking.
And this approximation
actually works
quite well in practice.
It's not a bound on the
probability of error given
a_j, but it's an
approximation.
And why did I do this?
Well, if I want to look at the
probability over all error,
what's that going to be?
It's going to be the average
over all possible a_j's of
probability of error
given a_j.
Now, so I want to take an
average of this quantity.
So this is a constant.
So I will just take the average
over this, and that's
going to be K_min of the
constellation, which is the
average number of nearest
neighbors, times Q of D_min
over 2 sigma.
This is approximate here.
So this is an approximation that
will be used, and it's a
very useful approximation,
and it is known as
the Union Bound Estimate.
It's no longer a bound
on the probability of
error, it's an estimate.
And in fact, there is a homework
problem where you
will be showing that the Union
Bound Estimate is in fact
exact for an M-PAM
constellation.
And I will let you think
why that is the case.
I was going to do it, but then
I realized it's a homework
problem, so you might as well
spend some time on it.
So the last thing that I wanted
to do today is find a
lower bound on the probability
of error.
So if I look at probability of
error, it's a union of bunch
of the events.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That union should be
with a_j prime.
PROFESSOR: The union should
be with a_j --
yeah.
It's not what I have?
So I'm taking a union over all
possible events, but a_j's
confused with a_j prime.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
a_j going to union j prime not
equal to j, a_j prime.
PROFESSOR: Oh, I see.
AUDIENCE: I think you need
parentheses around the --
AUDIENCE: Brackets
around the --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
another set of parentheses
behind the event a_j
going to a_j prime.
Because that's the event you
were talking about there.
At least that's [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So you are
saying that --
AUDIENCE: Put parentheses
after the u.
PROFESSOR: After the u.
Like this?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, right.
That's the event.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That's what I meant.
OK, fine.
Fair enough.
OK, so basically, the
lower bound is
actually quite simple.
All I'm going to do
is only take one
event from that union.
I'm only going to take one
point, which is the minimum
distance from a_j.
So probability of error given
a_j is greater than or equal
to probability that a_j goes
to a_j prime, where now a_j
prime is the nearest
neighbor of a_j.
And this we know from PAM
analysis is simply Q of d_min
over 2 sigma.
So this is a strict lower bound
on the probability of
error, and it has the
same exponent as
the Union Bound Estimate.
Of course, if I want to find
the overall probability of
error, I can just take
an average of this.
Since this is fixed, it's going
to be the same quantity.
So far what we have is a strict
upper bound on the
probability of error, which is
this quantity here, a union
bound estimate, and we have
a lower bound on the
probability of error.
In the next lecture, we will be
looking at how to use these
bounds to compute a probability
of error for small
signal constellations, and
quantify the performance
trade-off of the probability
of error versus the
EbN_0 and so on.
I think this is a natural
point to stop.
It's almost time now.